توقعات اشتباكاتهم مسلحه فجر اليوم بين
مقومنا وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بلده
قباطيه وتنظر لقطات المصوره التي نشرتها
منصات الفلسطينيه تحرك عربات الاحتلال في
احياء بلده وصنع اصوات الشباكات بالاسلحه
المتوسطه
هذا وتشهد كافه المدن والبلدات والقرى
العربيه داخل الخط الاخضر اضرابا شاملا
ردا على جريمه قتل شرطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الشاب محمد العصيبي من بلده
حوره في النقب خلال خروجه من المسجد
الاقصى الليله قبل الماضيه وقد شل الاضراب
الشامل الذي دعت اليه لجنه المتابعه
العليا لشؤون العرب داخل الخط الاخضر شلت
جهاز التعليمي والمحاله التجاريه والمرافق
الاخرى كافه ونددت كافه الفعاليات العربيه
داخل الخط الاخضر بالجريمه وكذبت روايه
شرطه الاحتلال التي ادعت انه حول
الاستيلاء على سلاح احد افرادها بينما قال
شهود عيان ان جنود الاحتلال اطلقوا الرصاص
عليه عندما حاول التدخل لحمايه فتاه
لاحقها الجنود
وفي القدس المحتله اثارت دائره الاوقاف
الاسلاميه باقتحام عشرات المستوطنين باحات
المسجد الاقصى من جهه باب المغاربه بحراسه
مشدده من الشرطه الاسراريه واضف دائره
الاوقاف ان الشرطه الاسرائيليه اخرجت
المعتكفين عنوه من المسجد وابعدت الشبان
عن مسار الاقتحامات وذكرت في بيان ان
المستوطنين اقتحموا ساحات الاقصى على شكل
مجموعات ضمت كل واحده اربعين مستوطنا
مستوطنا